greetings from podcastville it's monday
the [ __ ]
who knows what day it is i know it's the
last [ __ ] monday in june
the rent is due on wednesday taxes are
due on the 15th
and unemployment ends on the 31st so you
better pucker up [ __ ]
kick this [ __ ] mule lee
oh [ __ ] there you go no more [ __ ]
excuse
the [ __ ] me we're going in like
[ __ ] marines you understand me
welcome to church [ __ ]
[Music]
it's monday the 29th of june i hope
you're feeling better i hope you
powdered your nuts
last week was last week this week is
this week who gives a [ __ ]
i got my girl eleanor kerrigan in the
studio how are you
hi should i put my mask back on now that
you're smoking
nah we got the door open i've never been
high but i'll get a contact high from
you
joey nobody gets a contact side here we
got everything
we got lysol we got [ __ ] ebola spray
i got the [ __ ] they sprayed in black
people's eyeballs what is that
[ __ ] nigerian this is the [ __ ] that
just
michael jordan yeah black lives matter
[ __ ] you know i'm just trying to
protect myself you know what i'm saying
it's a good day to be alive everybody's
happy everybody's tip
top two how was kansas how was traveling
as a corona comic now that i'm the
corona comic i'm in that list i'm so
excited to finally make a group
uh no the corona kansas city was great
but i will say i was nervous like flying
only because i thought [ __ ] i better get
there early they're gonna take your
temperature
they're gonna do all this [ __ ] they
didn't do a [ __ ] thing i don't even
think they checked my license i gotta be
off they don't give a [ __ ] about flying
now do you see what americans doing
american
united they're not they're not gonna
have any open seats no
open seats no openc there was a guy i
had cuddled with a guy
the whole way oh no to and from
it was insane there's no open seating no
open seat it was nothing they were on
top of us and then i was in the airport
less than five minutes and almost killed
somebody because this guy there was no
flight that was leaving before 5 50 a.m
no [ __ ] flight and he was up my ass
when we were going through the thing and
i'm thinking six feet you
piece of [ __ ] right so then i go you
know what you go and i have put my stuff
through i go just go
and then he was uh what do you call that
pre-check or some [ __ ] that he'd have to
go through the
metal detector so he walked around the
side
and then my stuff came out first so he
picked my [ __ ] up
put it on top of somebody else's to get
his oh
and i go am i allowed to kill him and
the lady just laughs she goes
oh no he didn't and then she went over
and took care of it
and i was like black lives do matter get
him [ __ ] get him
it was great i was the whole comedy
experience for you like when you got to
the club
i was a nervous wreck but i i loved it
it was
so freeing it was so phenomenal but like
we i think we were talking about this
before about doing
material old material or whatever
like bc not before cry before corona you
know christ is gone it's we're bc now
before corona and so i was like what am
i gonna talk about
how are my bits gonna feel so i just for
the first 40 minutes
almost 45 the first night i did
just the [ __ ] that's been happening
during corona
and i was like this felt great that's
what i planned on doing
yeah it was like clearing and i mean of
course you you know because you're
living it
like i write things down but you don't
know if they're going to work
i'm going to open up who's got toilet
paper yeah
i'm saying what was the [ __ ] i want
to know right now
well i got 200 in here who went to the
store and bit toilet paper people
needing machines
people [ __ ] uh they can't breathe and
you got toilet paper
why does everybody [ __ ] who's got
toilet paper and explain yourself right
now
i want somebody to get up and go man i
still got a garage filled
yeah i don't know what i was thinking
people's houses look like a 99 cent
storefront
i bought a truck full of chuck toilet
paper now i got stomach cancer
you know what i'm saying i haven't taken
a [ __ ] in two weeks anyway so what am i
gonna do
i gotta put it on ebay cancer is toilet
paper
cool
[ __ ] it it's monday morning it was great
but also
this uh this new thing with the uh women
uh middle-aged white ladies losing their
[ __ ] minds all over the place you
know they're calling them karen's or
something
well my older sister's name is karen and
she is pissed
at all you [ __ ] she wants to
fight whoever came up with that
[ __ ] she's like you call me a karen i
will
knock you the [ __ ] out now where is this
north hollywood
uh training oh the traitor knocked down
over laurel canyon yeah yeah
you missed the strip if you miss your
exit we got to get off there sometimes
like there's nights i've been
high listening to us
you know there's night i go the other
way from the comedy store
i don't go laurel canyon okay you go a
long way it's tuesday so i'll stop at
joe's pizza
damn yeah and i go up to 101 and
sometimes you know
i [ __ ] have you ever gone through the
hills like behind the
store up like miller drop oh i love it
nothing scares the [ __ ] out of me more
and people do it to me all the time i
think it's because i'm a nice guy they
come up to me they're like hey joey
do you mind dropping us off up the hill
i don't know how many waitresses
have asked me you know when you just
want to go home
you just want to go home 30 seconds i
know but not even
wait it's not there but it's not for him
thank you lee
it's 30 seconds for an intelligent
individual okay
when you don't do chris chris when you
don't do
uh jigsaw puzzles and you know you never
were good at that game what's that game
what they did the
breakout i don't know yeah
when you're supposed to make a left but
you make a right that's not the guy you
want driving up your mouth
okay i get it dude one time i used to
live up there so it doesn't bother me
one time he got me high
and i was at home by myself he dropped
someone he dropped one of our friends
off
from the ice house like two minutes from
the ice house he called me
expected me to know where to get where
he was and i
i sent him the wrong way oh he's been
here for like 20 years
i've never gotten yelled at before he
sent him like up to 210 the wrong way
got two in the morning all you want to
do is get home you got to pee
you got a piece of [ __ ] lingering in
your ass and you're tired you just did
two shows
plus you're already gonna have insomnia
and also he tells me to go and it wasn't
his fault
you know number one i should not be
drunk people should know this thing
but don't you have an iphone i mean is
if i had a tank with military
instructions
i still i'm never going to press the
button that lady comes on and says
in 2.3 miles make a left that's never
going to happen
amazing why right because that's where
they make it you should
you should do it i gotta talk back to
her
i'll say things that you've never heard
before i'm already i can't hear you
anyway listen
yes you can i hear everything listen my
daughter [ __ ]
siri up you know siri on the ipad yeah
yeah she hates my daughter she
she hates mercy why mercy torments
mercy just doesn't ask her how long does
to take the nashville
mercy you'll go what if i have one foot
and a roller skate
and then she keeps doing that she should
always try to break it out so seriously
[ __ ] you and mercy with a little face
like what did i do wrong oh you asked
the 18
i've never done that one i've never
talked to siri she tortured sherry so
bad so he just went off like bloop
and my daughter's like siri come back
who wrote this song
and you know siri come back siri come
back
should be a song oh my god that's
amazing yeah i've done the
um waze app or the whatever and gotten
lost
ways is the worst ways waves takes you
out 18 miles
you've used waze no but you did one time
i almost stabbed you
next thing you know we're in chicago
they'll take you back we're in chicago
we're headed to irvine i just 30 minutes
in chicago to go to irvine yeah they try
to take your macros
and then they get lost i think yeah i
swear i think they get lost because i'm
like you don't know this [ __ ] back
road
see i used to live up on kings road it's
behind the comedy store
i lived me richie taylor the manager we
lived in
1501 queens road er queens road yeah
that's what it was not kings queens
so because they're two side by side
queen and kings
so we lived on queens road so i was
always up there and then working for
mitzi i was always on crest hill
because she still had the house um she
didn't sell it until
early 2000s maybe took a long time to
sell that one but
it the cresto was up there so i was
always up that hill so it's simple for
me i already know how to like navigate
around it
and when i first moved there i used to
walk all the hills so i was like oh this
connects
oh you can drive through here so if i'm
all the way at sunset plaza i can get to
the comedy store
through the hills jesus well i thought
my dad was
my favorite thing to do i got too high
and i kept missing turns
but you can't really do a u-turn on
those hills i went all out from here
they're like this big that was
terrifying
to me like 45 minutes i'm very very good
hollywood sunset i believe you go
through
side streets and like alleys in
hollywood well i know everything if the
cops chase me i will lose you
right that's my thing that's why i'm
really good at knowing where i'm going
running brother in hollywood no
hollywood just has you know hollywood
has
traffic listen we all have i hate
cities that doesn't have to happen
it's that we're all pointed at that same
direction
if you do you okay
when i used to live with terry we lived
on schrader
off the sunset in summer right by the
hollywood why
not right by the hollywood y and i had
two choices
when i left at night i could shoot down
to sunset
make a right catch island traffic
catch the brand traffic and then once
you hit
we're talking about 2001
ninety two thousand to two thousand six
once you hit laurel canyon
it was bumper to bump on a saturday
night i remember telling marlon marilyn
martinez and the husband
god rest their soul to get in the middle
lane we got a spot just get in the
middle lane and cut all through
and we ran right into his sheriff and he
gave us all tickets
we got to the store late because between
all the rock clubs
all those artsy fartsy clubs no it was
bumping the bumper
so then i figured out a way here's the
way you avoid all that [ __ ] you hook and
you stand selma
to your island there's a light there
it's summer again mm-hmm all the way
till you hit
like what's the other one guard uh curse
on no
curson didn't have a light the one by
coaching horses
you go yeah it's a one-way there's a
one-way after sunset you go down that
way
and that takes you down to what kenneth
said not to drink when you drink
fountain fountain and fountain would
take me to the bottom
of the mexican sweets
mm-hmm sweets are you pop up you make a
left
and it was still drama between the coach
house oh yeah
the goddamn it was still saddle ranch
whatever the [ __ ] what i avoided 30
minutes
by doing that wow one time i had joey
i'm not even sure why
because i know i wasn't doing stand-up
but it was me you schubert
in my car i was driving to the store
uh and i was going up sunset
i mean um sweets are from fountain to
sunset
and i was about to make the left and
joey go don't miss that [ __ ] light
[ __ ] okay
you missed that light we're here for
another [ __ ] hour and you're like
yelling in my ear and i'm like gunning
it of my little toyota
yellow dick yellow means step on it
where i come from
i see a yellow or you're going and a
little bit of red who cares about this
and if it's a little red weird screaming
every day
ain't no cops around every day i make
that
when i would go to the store i think you
now that we live
in the same building or i had a friend
that lived in your building and i would
go over there oh yeah
so you lived on my town night sunset
martial seven
they're from 97. i lived there for 12
years and i lived around the corner
with josh wolf on vista vista
it was it was gardner i don't know why i
make it gardner a lot of the times well
it was cartel
it was uh martel vista
gardner i think it was yeah sierra
bonita
you and a gay guy lived my roommate
not the ruler oh somebody else some a
gay comic from
the comedy store libbed on martel
okay josh wolfe
lived on vista
ralphie lived on gardner it was oh
okay lived on sierra bonita with nick de
paulo
wow and dr stanhope lived
on dougie's building had a lot of people
in that was party central
right yeah party central in the low rent
department
right because it was down the corner
from didn't jody and them live in there
too
jody moved in in 98 and all that stuff
so
stanhope lived across the street if all
standout had to do is wake up walk two
blocks
across the street and he'd be at
coaching horses yes so the
the everybody went to coaching horses
that was the
main thing right next to samuel french
right next to samuel france
i i have i probably gave them and fifty
thousand dollars to become a [ __ ]
some people give a college a hundred
thousand dollars a year same
and they're still morons i have so many
[ __ ] stories if you if you owe
student loans right now
i do not want you to feel guilty because
we gave a guy named samuel
french a wing to his the door yeah
i i do not throw this it's probably
still open that's close
horses is closed i don't even know the
same
[Music]
yes there was one right there and
there was one on sunset
you know how much money acting class
when i was when i talked to you about me
and eleanor we used to have a lot of
conversations about acting
illinois used to date an agent that was
big time that went off the
she was engaged to him my first
ex-fiance and he went off the defense he
was a typical agent he was jerry maguire
with a colombian guy next year he was he
was different than jerry maguire because
he
uh got fired for catering to his black
clients
and then when he got fired they all left
with him
so he was like his clients were martin
lawrence chris rock
um tommy davidson adele givens
um i know i'm missing somebody martin
lawrence i said right
martin chris that was his big guys oh
and russell simmons who had this idea of
like
hey we should start a black comedy show
uh
def jam so they all were part in all of
that
every single thing um trying to think of
who else he had like ricky harris all
those guys
every black comic left with him and then
they became superstars and then william
morris brought him back
and then he went off the deep end but
he's better
and he's married and has a kid so i'm
happy for him but
i would have had 10 children with him
had he kept his [ __ ] together
this was what year 97 when i met in 96.
i started dating him like 94.
yeah i met him right when i first moved
i i started 93 at the store
and then i met him he was like coming in
he would come in with worthy patterson
remember worthy worthy is his best
friend
should have known sorry worthy i should
have known he's
very good i love worthy where is he
she's great i still talk to him every
once in a while yeah i will
because i talked to michael hubbard
still and very honest
worthy yeah he told you it was on his
mind
he told you yeah what he couldn't do for
you and he told you when he couldn't do
something for you and you couldn't take
offender that you'd put your head down
and turn away
but then you go how many people haven't
been honest with me
right this guy's honest with him he
bought me a lunch he bought me
when bobby lee tells that story about us
being poor
yeah that's funny you brought him up but
yeah yeah
me and bobby were no food to eat pretty
much three days away from homeless at
the [ __ ]
latino laugh festival it was him who
took us out to dinner when he found out
we had no money
nothing yeah where he's a good guy i
mean i break his balls because i know a
little too much
but um he he's very funny whatever he's
very honest but we were doing
a show for michael hubbard for this um
i'm going to slip on what the benefit
was for but it was to raise money for
schools or something
inner city schools and worthy showed up
because hubbard is martin's guy
he does everything for martin for years
and from all the way back with billy
i think he's like his manager or
something um so hubbard uh
was there so worthy showed up and so
we're in the back talking like it's
1994. you know where do we go way back
so we're laughing and joking about
something then bobby lee comes up
and bobby was like well if you're still
mad at me
immediately it turned into it with him
such a thing
we left that saturday from dinner we're
gonna sign with you
thank you bobby did sign with him did he
yeah
yeah it was crazy but he didn't pay he
didn't
pay him or he didn't pay somebody
residuals and they had a fight over it
not residuals um you know uh commission
commissions
i don't know if it was worthy he didn't
pay or another manager i forget but they
immediately was like i don't give a [ __ ]
but they immediately went
at it he's like you should have done it
you should like it was like nothing
left they were still on that fight from
the day they
but then they hugged and they were fine
it was just made me laugh so hard
but bobby did sign with him that's why
we had a big fight with him because me
and freddie
told him not to sign with worthy sorry
worthy but he knows all this
it's crazy how we were [ __ ] kids
just kids well people don't realize we
i got you in here today to cover a
couple things
but i wanted people in the know the
state of mind like
we had this thing come out with the
video with rogan last week right
made a lot of people open up their eyes
and i'm not mad at you
like i said uh on the instagram
i want women to take a stand but it's
where it's going
what i wanted to do today is since
eleanor was there from 97
93 93 was give you the state of mind
of what was there now something i
brought up that was really
when it first came out a lot of people
ran for the hills
and it was the movie by motley crue
oh dirt or whatever the dirt right
and if anybody knows that movie the
opening scene is a party
above the uh whatever and
they come in and you know they're motley
crew they're just
the best band on the sunset strip at the
time
they're not even the kings of rock yet
or maybe they are
and uh some chick they sit it down
in front of 30 people she spreads her
legs
tommy lee eats a [ __ ] or i don't know
which one
i have i remember it yeah and she sprays
the room with [ __ ] juice
she was talented and she wanted to
showcase her talents
and i don't i'm not mad at her you look
at that as a
non member of a band not music band
you look at that as a normal human being
especially in these times and you look
at it and you go
what type of [ __ ] behavior does that
turn that off or
who would do something like that and my
world would people forget is
i'm a [ __ ] prude and i'm a catholic i
was raised to be approved
and i'm still very brutish i don't do a
lot of things that most
that's so funny i hear you say that but
i like it i'm not a playboy guy
right i don't like porn if there's a
chick [ __ ] on my twitter feed
how weird is that that she's sucking
three black dicks on my twitter feed
i gotta watch it i don't another
talented young lady don't hate
don't do it so quickly you can't even
bang one out don't get me wrong
yeah first of all one bang went out in
the eye in the computer because god
knows who's got your
eye on you when you bang it out yeah
tripoli's got all my [ __ ] covered
everybody else whatever but uh
you know you see all these things i'm
not a porno guy i've never been
it makes sense i went to a triple x on a
sunday night
because my friends had to go and some
guy tried to like [ __ ]
not touch me in the bathroom but he said
creepy things to me when i was 18.
in jersey that were disgusting during
the week
they showed three movies and five hours
two dollars during the week
and on sundays they had a triple x bar
yeah and one night we went it was just
[ __ ]
pedophile like that's what they take it
on a pedophile school trip
yeah like when you're in a pedophile
side of the prison they take you to the
triple x show on sundays
and these [ __ ] dudes will be doing oh
my god
you could smell sperm in the air your
feet are sticking yeah
you're stepping on fetuses this
just you know abortion doctors are there
scraping yeah [ __ ]
as they should be just just creepy [ __ ]
you know
i went to one of those and it wasn't for
me but do you love [ __ ] yeah
you love the idea of love you love the
idea of
eating ass you're a hopeless romantic
joey you know so for right now
people looking at the article they're
planning on doing is
looking at comedy as a whole with the
comedy store being the epicenter
and how that no and it's not because
for years kennison's stories came out of
the comedy store
and now they're you know coming again
whether our friend crystal lee was an
undergraduate
on the great rage girls which i never
saw him with
did i see him with [ __ ] like like you
thought he was [ __ ] running a miss
america
god bless him but that was years i
thought like he's just the host of this
american guy yeah
they're all trying to take him out to
dinner explain to him they walk off the
stage and they go
crazy what do you want to do for the
world well i want to start with world
peace and
i want to bring apples back you know
what i'm saying yeah
and i want to meet crystalia yeah so i
thought chris was just running the world
yeah i didn't know they were under it i
would never think of that but i was
thinking it was a joke or no joke
nobody in this table knew any idea of
underage stuff
whatever's been coming out has been
coming out it's news to us
there's no cover-up there's no
nothing but i was thinking of this like
the comedy store is 21 and over right
right so it's a little harder to sneak
in if you're
16-17 right especially now now it's
ridiculous now it's like fort knox but
before the laugh factory and the improv
have always been
18 and over always because they serve
food
so we didn't have food up until recently
and then i was pissed i was like you're
not going to change the age limit right
because comedy store is
wild and it works better as 21 and over
so what i'm saying is like these girls
could have been sneaking it it's easier
to sneak in
if it's 18 and older and you're 17. meet
chris
and i'm not saying like if he did
something wrong that's terrible but it's
it's a lot easier at 17 to go meet a guy
at a comedy club that you've been dying
to meet you know what i mean like
i was sneaking in clubs when i was 15
years old well even without
the questalia thing like it blew my mind
when i moved to la
that people drink like even regular jobs
people go
and get hammered at lunch oh yeah oh
yeah my mom
yeah yeah i know this is a and not not
to make excuses for it but this is a
different town this is
this is the town of when i moved here
you had open bars at christmas parties
and people would get hammered this is
the first place i saw coke you this is
oh really oh yeah where did you grow up
in a bubble yeah
okay i mean yeah i mean i i i'm not i
don't speak for all of boston but
for a suburb boston you're gonna bring
up boston suburbs oh no no yeah i was
i was a very the white one i'm the child
for white privilege
but uh it's i think there's a lot of
people who didn't grow up seeing there's
some people who didn't
like lexington yeah right right that's
where my ex lived from
but it's just like this is a it's hard
to judge
this city based off of like normal
business practices it's i mean it's just
it it's it's apples and oranges i think
oh absolutely and i i've seen
one percent of it i can't imagine being
there every night
and and and having access to drugs and
having
all that extra or no money like it's
just it's
it's uh this is a very different place i
think
i i think like you you might be right i
mean i just
i grew up different i grew up in south
philadelphia
drugs were always around people did them
people didn't do them
some people did crazy things on them
some people didn't do anything they just
existed you know functioning drug
addicts whatever
and like i said i was 15 i was in
nightclubs taking pictures of people
literally my friend hired me in her
after hours nightclub
to take pictures and i was wearing like
a little dress that
was the size of a scrunchie and it was
like fluorescent
and i would go around taking pictures of
people and charge them ten dollars
but i was they hired me to do that like
she didn't know i was that young i was
like yeah
and then my older brother who worked
with her was like yeah yeah she's fine
because i was 15 going on 35
like we grew up different we you know
i'm one of ten i've
my dad moved out when i was seven so we
were like
wow because my mom would call us wild
indians not to be racist but
she kind of is uh
but in a fun way like she would be like
you guys are wild like
you know she would try to control how
are you gonna control 10 kids six boys
four girls
in a in south philly we you know are
i have friends that are doing life in
prison i have friends that
have been killed by cops i have i've
watched cops beat people like
nothing is surprising to me like i'm not
sure what they're gonna
what so when i moved to hollywood yeah
you see a different element
but i'm i i saw and this is gonna sound
crazy but i saw a more privileged ele
uh element like if people had
credits they got away with things if
people had you know money they got away
with things i was like oh wow
okay it's funny that now
uh because of what i found about people
making calls to seattle and denver
it's so crazy they're gonna go after
comedy scenes in general mm-hmm and then
calmly as a whole
and yeah it's gone and where it's
happened and i could tell you something
you know let's go back to july of 91.
i get into comedy i'm just happy that
people accepting me i'm doing
right one gig a month i get into a
contest
i win the contest i become the house nc
of this place
this is denver or seattle this is
boulder boulder
i started in denver now i'm in boulder i
dig this waitress she's got a boyfriend
nothing
happens i dig this other waitress
and we start dating you know so the
whole year and a half
she drops a bomb on me she's going to
see it in new york to be a pr
chick and i started dating a roommate
and
that went on until february of 93
and then you know that was really
my whole comedy at that time was the
broker
my house and every once in a while i get
to ask do a gig on a saturday night
i really wasn't committed to comedy so
it was like it was just me getting my
feet wet
i was learning just mondays was
mind-boggling
because it was 15 for a steak yeah
and the comedy and the ticket and people
really went to get the steak
and they gave you a shrimp bowl so
you had to be funny in the shrimp bowl
[ __ ] nobody is funnier than a shrimp
when you haven't eaten all day and
[ __ ] you know i'm saying so
okay it was a real adventure for me to
learn i love nobody okay
so when i went to me then i went to new
york
and in new york you have no friends
right
comedy for nine months and then the only
guy i knew was mike bushetti
oh i love michael i didn't meet nobody
they're foot soldiers out there yeah i
went to
i said let me go to colorado and that's
when i turned down the comedy heat
and that's when i became part you become
of clicks
sure you become part of the open mic
click and they accept you
and then you take a chance and do a gig
with a feature act and now he invites
you
to that feature of click where even the
mc gets fifteen dollars and you get a
free drink ticket
and now there's women at those shows and
trying to talk to you in this
new female comics there's new fair mail
comics in the uh
in the new comics yeah sure and then but
we're all just around each other right
now and then one day you get to
do a show and you get to meet one of the
areas biggest headliners
and he invites you to a barbecue so now
you're part of that and that was one of
the best times of my life in boulder
when i was part of all three crews
i got to hang out with you know open
micros on
tuesdays and thursdays and then
wednesdays and thursdays
i hung out with guys in the feature acts
and
and then little by little bunk comedy
works came and i started doing guest
spots and my mom
what's her name wendy comedy wendy's
great she's great
and uh when i started going with the
features
they were the wildest open mikers were
okay but they went home they had day
jobs
the features got a little tasty that's
what it was the features
snorted coke and got together after the
[ __ ] comedy game
by the way not all of us do that but
like yeah just for features
if you if you were gonna take a
percentage these are features emcees
guys that were going to not favorable
places but we were in the game
yeah these guys were in the game and
they had [ __ ] hanging around
you know little girls that hung around
some of them wanted to be comics but
i have a different message i'm working
on it
the package will be together more spoken
word yeah there's more spoken word with
grenades going off
you know it's like apocalypse now me
[ __ ] luanne
what's a chinese whatever
oh [ __ ] she's not chinese isn't it i
guess
i like it my daughter was giving me an
earbud
is great yeah so you know you make these
girls and you snuck up with them and
then when i was first involved when i
went back in 94 i just walked into
nothing but trouble like i walked into
going to war with my ex-wife
mm-hmm and then i knew a guy and we were
tight
and i knew his girlfriend and they were
tight and they had a kid
and one night i saw an open mic and
she's like i've been dying to talk to
you
me and emma done i think it's me and you
time to get together and
i'm awesome i'm living in a hotel with
her the kid
and an ounce of coke and you know sounds
like a fun day he would come pick up the
kid i'd leave
and like come back and it was just three
months and then finally one day it came
to me because i'm trying to get back
with it
stop giving a stab and just because
you're driving the crazy
and i walked away from her and then you
know it was just it was just the life of
[ __ ] man
yeah that people the general eye does
not understand that
it's just mayhem like one night we were
talking about two hours they were having
sex with coke and [ __ ] like that and
then
uh i didn't have any girlfriends
i swear to god you didn't have any like
friend friends
interesting i didn't have a girlfriend i
had eleanor
who texted me every 10 days to see if i
had blow and i go yeah
are you by yourself yeah yeah and come
over
i like that you said eleanor who's never
done coke in my life
i'll take a stabbing from the old days
don't be coming over here with a friend
you know if you come to mind i see what
you mean yes and most guys do
yeah don't be bringing people i only got
coke for two people
and that's this i'm gonna give you asp
don't bring a group don't bring a group
brett
i'm gonna see how [ __ ] i get it i was
just doing this yeah as a whale life guy
and i had three of those so it was any
week i could get a call from one girl on
a tuesday
night when i was snorting i'm just
getting back from an open mic
you know and then what do you think
happens one day i go to this
con we do tuesday nights at the comedy
works
and we're all there the features the mcs
the open mics and they close it up and
we're drinking
and you have to at that time it was like
going into a coliseum and a girl
and one of the girls was like joey and
she jumps and she jumps at me and i grab
her
i give her a hug we go to the bar do we
snort coke no do we [ __ ] do i try to
[ __ ] know
three days later i'm getting a call from
wendy you got banned
you grabbed her ass i go ask her i
didn't grab her ass yes you did
then i came to find out the manager made
up a lie and they redeemed the other and
i bumped into wendy's at the one of the
festivals
and she's like i know you're mad at me
well i'm not mad at you why would i be
mad at you you saved my life i would
have been in jail for murder
yeah because i killed my ex-wife and
look what you did you [ __ ]
threw me out and it was the god brought
me here and there we are
and wendy goes you know what i'm lifting
the band because it was always [ __ ]
anyway
so where there's smoke there's fire yeah
then you have a thing called the road
when you go on the road if you don't
believe me don't look at don't
listen to me pick any artist you like
and read their life on the road
yeah on the road let me tell you that
women come and going i don't know why
they come and go and at that age you're
not even thinking about it you just got
lucky
you don't have to deal with them again
you weren't looking to fall in love
right and you get in your car and then i
go to seattle seattle i'm up there with
a girlfriend the whole time
so there was no outside
uh towards the end i dated a little girl
for a while that had to look bad
don't say little girl but yeah yeah yeah
stop it now every time i try to hug her
the acne would be no
would it believe oh please no markings
you see this little tick that comes out
of my stomach what do you call those oh
yeah like a little mole
a skin tag
joey that's like an oath that's a
[ __ ] so i moved out shrek
i moved with my girlfriend and then we
broke up like in 90 [ __ ]
seven she moved back to michigan
and i was out here by myself and my road
got my top my car my apartment got towed
your apartment was your car yeah that
lived on ralphie may's floor
and here i am at the store you know did
you live with ralphie
i was i lived on this floor and i got
okay took a shower at the store at 9 15.
sure sure so many uh homeless people
take a shower in the morning and i come
back at 7 15 and take another shot
chewy would say why are you here so
early i gotta look at something in the
main room
i gotta remember i had a bag with gel
oh yeah foot stuff for my foot fungus
you take a shower at the store
you gotta be careful yeah that's true it
comes with it yeah
do you remember mac lindsay do you
remember him yeah oh he was so [ __ ]
funny where is he
he's in texas i think right now but he
was living in new york
and um we're funny funny on to something
so [ __ ] he was just crazy obsessed
i loved him too but he literally was
like living out of a van
in the back of the comedy store and he
would take a shower
but he wasn't quiet about it like mac
wasn't the kind of guy that would just
be quiet like whisper
so he would come out on the main room
stage in a row there's no show going on
this is daytime and the manager would
walk in
what are you doing dean gelber bro what
are you doing and mac would be like
taking a shower but he'd have a robe
like it was crazy it was crazy it's
unbelievable it really was
it was one of my favorite people in the
world and again i do not want to
let's just go back to the three
histories the last factory really had no
history in my life
it had a history of just a club it's
very small too
the improv's history was known for let's
be honest as
the improv was uh robin williams
uh bud friedman evening at the improv
sure why are you giving them robin i
mean i like it let's just
hear what you're saying i i can't think
of the guy's name right now they had a
certain
that a certain amount yes they preferred
a working comic
to a certain comic but the comedy store
since the night i was reading the
belushi thing
oh yeah and de niro and robin williams
were at mario and charlie's up the
corner where the union became
where where did where did dean dean came
become the king with
oh dang cook the uh um jesus what the
hell was it called jay
the dublins the dublins my god america
was dublin's it was called mario or
something
okay and there was a hangout and they
also did comedy there
and de niro and robin williams and the
bungalows are right there
uh [ __ ] nut was across the street at the
bungalows belushi
belushi and i'd like to say
robin and de niro
walked to the comedy store to see if
fryer was there yes
to one that's true to do coke with
belushi in that room
yeah brian had left with appointed
sisters
and all and he walked over they walked
over there
and found the cocaine right there as a
child
my curiosity opened up yeah you're like
wait this
is the legendary went to the comedy
store yeah
and then you know before i lived in a
seat when i lived in seattle
somebody gave me the uh the [ __ ]
uh kennyson book
oh uh the biography by chelsea
if you just read wired by uh i can't
remember
everybody's in it it's all about snl
right snl wild
right why so you you read all this [ __ ]
so this isn't new to people and you hear
this [ __ ]
for me from what i had heard the
beatings the angel salazars
the chemists the girlfriends the
abortions
the mitzi the wait a minute
i chose the comedy store the comics i
had worked with on the road
from james stevens iii to louis ck
at that time doug stanhope all these
guys
like the store is waiting for you and
i'm like really and they're like
people would ask me two things from day
one as sheriff met you and has met him
at you
since they were yeah those are the two
people
but people always ask me if i knew but i
feel like the store
it's so big and it was so easy to get
lost in there and there were so many
dark corners if you will
now you were there 93 what was the store
in 93
when i like i said when i first got
there i
i was i was new i was like okay what is
this you know it was wild
and we had they had just had the uh 92
riots
they had just had that rodney king all
that nonsense was just happening i
remember my mother being like so nervous
like
there's riots i'm like yeah but it's i'm
sure it's like philadelphia you know
what am i going to be afraid of l.a i'm
from philly we have the same ship
whatever
so i remember going and we had
monday nights was the all black night
eddie griffin
ran a room uh every room was all black
shows which was great
like they were fun but they were wild
and they were wild in that
like they would always i remember my
friend gabrielle
uh she somebody said to her uh hey can
you bring a drink
to so and so and they said the name and
she brought a drink
and here it was a gang rival and uh a
big brawl broke out in the o.r
it was awful and gabrielle was just like
crawling out of there this is like this
gorgeous blonde
they used to call her susie chapstick
every single time we worked together in
a black room
so whatever it was but gabrielle could
hold her own so she didn't care
but we were they too ripped a ashtray
off the wall we used to have those metal
ashtrays remember though
[ __ ] wong it at her like it was wild
so
my idea was like okay this is like being
in the streets
do you know what i mean like [ __ ]
there's urban shows i just go right back
to
that mindset then there was a shootout
that meant he got nervous
the guy i came down here to audition
and i stayed in studio city real close
to here
i still see the guy around town that i
stayed with wow
he did a favor for a friend of a friend
he was a writer on mad tv
he was very nice to me he took me i mean
okay i stayed with him and he him and
his wife showed me hospitality took me
to
the japanese arsons i don't even know
what that means
the corner there used to be a japanese
place where he'd sing on the table
and karaoke i don't want to work i don't
want to play on these
i wouldn't go there it was like musou
and frank's the japanese tools
they had a line out there not miss
ellie's i mean that's another thing
okay right near the store oh oh okay i'm
sorry i'm going japanese got it
in the valley what the [ __ ] was it they
burnt it down it was called
tokyo tokyo oh wow i've never heard of
that they took me to tokyo
very nice i showcased and i still
remember going
he goes is there anything you'd want to
do after your showcase because he drove
me down to the lab factory
you showcased at the laughter factory
for the latino laugh festival
oh okay yeah and i didn't meet anybody
it was very cold
man this place is [ __ ] up and i had
two connections
real weird i had the connection of my
friend
that ron hooked me up with that took me
to the
lab factory okay and i drove from
seattle
okay so you you're by yourself wow
but then when i was at the lab factory
i had excused the guy who drove me down
and he waited
while i went to the deli next door
what's the deli next to the laugh
factory uh greenblatt and spoke to a
friend of mine
that my goomba jersey his
wife her brother was in like five movies
oh okay so i met with him
and he's like here's the advice i got to
give you come back you got into this
acting class
he was i think he was like he was like
us he was just a working step
and he had gotten into a hot movie with
john vlan claude dom whatever his name
is
the real thing why i met him was he was
jason scott lee's jason bruce lee's sons
oh roommate for two years and he had
become dear friends
wow so i went to meet with him to talk
about that we just talked about a lot of
things sure kung fu guy yeah
he told me all this stuff he told me you
invented it no
he told me all this dumb [ __ ] about
hollywood to avoid
if i moved down here and to call him
when i came down here
and years later he called me goes what
the [ __ ] you doing better than i am
i go yeah thank you for taking me to
lunch
because he had he went dead after that
movie and i moved down he
started putting commercials and tv right
right i'm watching everywhere what the
[ __ ]
isn't that weird i should have charged
you for that talk
you know but i went to the store
and i knew it was home it was dark
the land of misfit toys i felt something
weird in there
and then we have to go back to
sundays and mondays where i used to host
from itsy
they give me a list of the people that i
call in were we just mondays
at that point at that point it was
sundays i mean i'm sorry just sundays
because she it was monday she moved it
because monday night football getting
off lights
and going straight to the store in my
luggage right and putting in the
waitress station
washing my face washing my hands and
going and doing
10 to 11. she dug me she gave me the 25
door spot sure from eight to ten and
then you did the door spot
[ __ ] yeah i don't think i remember you
on the door
nobody does how long did it last
about a year and a half it was like a
thank you for hosting
here's a little extra something for you
would you actually stand at the door
i would stand with you you would combust
people's balls let me see your id
what was the day to your birth what
country you were born
wow so at 10 o'clock i relieved that to
somebody
that post disappeared i picked up a
check for 25. i like that you had your
own thing going on
because i don't even know what that
means and then i'd go host at 10
25 now again i got the small
25 to host do you think
at four you got less than that on the
door right or was it 25
on the door and 25 to host so it's 50.
50 50. 15.
oh you mean q together 50 yes
oh see you would get 25 to host i'd walk
50. i'd walk out of sundays with 50
bucks okay
now so joey didn't have it any easier
i said let me throw an extra kick on
this why am i up here arguing with these
guys
they're never gonna get a spot yeah even
if god wants to take this mitzi is gonna
scratch oh no
these [ __ ] even if you slept
with mitzi it wasn't guaranteed to get a
spot
you could have pitched the tenth out
there and been number one since sunday
[ __ ] going i'm gonna be number one
that wasn't gonna happen
oh my god because i would get on the
phone and call mooney
eddie and joe rogan and go i don't know
if you know i'm hosting tonight
and you come out and try out all your
new material it's my favorite
and andrew come on down really what time
get there at ten the [ __ ] 10.
surprise some open micros haven't killed
you
they don't know about it so they'd be
there going yes
they would be calling their homes the
whole thing like i'm getting on stage at
the store it was
comics who weren't getting stage time
that mitzi
looked at and said you know what i made
a mistake
that's what it really was by the way
that she told me yeah she told me once
she goes these are comics i made a
mistake with and i don't want them
around here no more
and the only way to get rid of them is
not to pull them up on sundays because i
don't want to give them a false hope
unless i hear something spectacular from
scott
at the time scott day yeah she goes i'm
not playing games with these people
but this is this is without a thousand
people trying to get to the store dog
yeah even even more so than now your
wait list was six
and you could and if she saw you six
months ago and she saw you again
you thought i'll just do the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
bye she remembered every word so
when i did that i would call mooney
whatever and i would
also not have morning dice yeah could
you can you imagine every three minutes
you have to change the color oh
and you got to walk up this down the
stairs trust me i host it for like three
years
come on i'm on coke i'm gonna be walking
up wasting coke
you know i need this energy so i would
put uh
i would do ten or four steps wait do you
do that four steps
i did everything three years ago they
hated me i was there i was there
oh you did it yeah i couldn't walk for
four days after that those days are done
with up and down
this ain't no tight fit classes it
really is the best way to grow though
it is the best way to grow it took me
mitzi was nice enough to let me
when i first started doing stand-up
after being a waitress for so long and
she hated when a waitress turned comic
let me tell you
she [ __ ] hated that because i watched
it too
and i would be like and then they
[ __ ] get on stage in front of her and
she'd like get rid of
them and i'd be like all right so i had
to fire plenty of waitresses who stunk
on stage
so it's so bad sunday nights i get off
that stage
and everybody will be depressed [ __ ] you
know how long andrew's going to do he's
going to do till once
we're doing two more albums what's the
truth go down the corner go
you're wasting all this energy to get
back in here yeah she's talking
you could have wrote an hour you could
have done so many
things and i understand the pain you had
but now
let's eliminate that let's take back but
why not go where
go where people [ __ ] with you like if if
the comedy store doesn't
like you go somewhere there's a million
other [ __ ] places you never stay in
one spot
when it's time you'll be here yeah but
right now don't mess with it now let's
talk about the second part of this
in the video i spoke about 23 years ago
what was going on up there
for women now eleanor hasn't sucked the
deck to my knowledge and i've known her
for years
i mean if i would like she would tell me
to get stage time
oh whitney cummings didn't suck a dick
allie wong didn't suck a dick
you know eliza didn't suck a dick i'm
not saying they're having to suck the
dick somewhere
in their personal lives you know how
many people say to me whitney [ __ ]
everybody together and i go what are you
i was right there in the trenches with
her you know what i'm saying like people
will tell you out of jealousy
and it's a jealousy created by other
women i agree
it's a jealousy created by other women
when i got back to the store
like i said last week before we even
said this there was a rumor going around
that women running against stage time so
when you see me looking at the list
i'm not looking at the list to see what
time it is
and i would count and go i don't know
what these women are talking about
so to least lease in the burden
i started putting more women on my
podcast more women that yeah
we would know about just to lease in
that okay
that's great joey you did that you're a
great guy
[ __ ] you're gonna be a saint let's not
get away from the situation
but you're the kind of person you don't
care about gender you're
funny is funny funny is funny and i want
to give a spotlight the same spotlight
people gave me sure
the way rogan gave me a spotlight and
richard jenny gave me a spotlight you
probably
took me to vegas oh no i didn't these
are all spotlights these are all
spotlights these are
you have to be very thankful of these so
but let's talk about 97 to 2000.
i had never seen more of a collection of
crazier people in my life
and i tell you guys how it is what came
close
the tenderloin in 85 when i lived there
for that summer
came close to my first year at the store
my first year
tenderloin san francisco oh my first
year at the store was
peter chen the guy who they said i
killed
that disappeared the old man oh uh
it'll come to me yeah yeah he's alive
yeah yeah
um you know gay lord
gaylord dingler hitting the guy with the
car
and then there's a situation of women
that went up there on sunday nights now
again
i am not downplaying what i said on
with rogan i'm not downplaying it i just
want to give you guys a back
pedal okay nobody lied
nobody exaggerated it was just told
in a quick the way and this is my
witness right here
we just spoke about the original room
for the last 30 minutes
i never even did sex in the belly room
nobody that's just
i mean i do i love it but at that time
it was weird
it was weird adam adam barnhart had a
great show
on sunday night and that's it nobody
else had to show up there
well it was rachel lovey she used to
have three shows but it was more
again geared toward women like rachel
had great comparisons
this is just to prove to you people that
when you tell a story you get caught up
in the story
sure there were skippy levels they were
different
whiskey love there were different women
that went up there on sundays
we could mention they i remember one in
particular okay
how to pick convertible mercedes to not
say her name
i'm never going to say her name i know
exactly what you're talking
but the guy the old man she was living
with was like 70.
something like that he would buy
everything her promo packages
dresses and but the tits he got a
the doctor in mexico forgot to move the
vein underneath it
i hate you and put the pit the vein over
the pit
and it looks so bad but there was there
was
ladies and gentlemen and i have two
daughters
i have 10 nieces and i have 200 women
that i'm dear friend with yeah looking
at you in the eye and i'm telling you
to correct me if i'm lying to you there
was six or seven women in those days
that didn't want to do whitney's work
they didn't want to do that they didn't
want to put the leg work in
they didn't want to put the leg work in
and they taunt you
and they'd say things to you and they'd
start with they were looking for
shortcuts they'd start with
guilt yeah well you have this and i
don't have this
and you're so lucky and why can't you
put me up in front of mitzi and blah
blah blah
and it never you know for me it never
understood nobody ever came out
beside that girl and said how about i
trade your blow job for stage time and
it was
the weirdest thing because i had had a
sexual relationship
before okay literally a year earlier
and we would hook up once a month on a
weird situation
once we actually hooked up in an
apartment yeah
she came over and she goes but she
partied too yeah
i'm just making sure i got the same
thing yeah okay
and she goes and i'm not hating her for
any of this by the way
like we joke about these girls make
comedy better for a lot of people yeah
so she said
i've got these for eight packages i
bought them from
and i want to do them and i said i have
an 11 45 spot
no but i have to go now it's a friday
night
and i'm like oof that's spock and wait
i'm a little burnt out on stand up
i was opening up for paul rodriguez on
saturday and sunday
and fresno baker's okay
bob bob baker uh no yourself
no the guy that ran houston at the time
was doing independent contact
con uh concerts
oh and i said i never forget looking at
her in the eye and going
i got 11 45 spot
if i go home with you i just want you to
know
we ain't [ __ ] around i'm gonna put
you to work
and she goes what does that mean and i
go we're gonna do coke so obviously
somewhere along the night
we're gonna wanna [ __ ] it's gonna get
out of control gonna get wild and she's
like well
okay fine she goes i just don't give
good enough head
and i'm like like already i'm like
that's hysterical
because you got to teach me how to give
ahead
you know okay and i went over there oh
all right she was a professional you
know i'm saying
and we spent that night together and
there was a couple nights at the store
okay and then she was frustrated and i
get it she was frustrated she was
frustrated not with me
because she was getting beat up
everywhere at that time she was getting
beat up at the improv
she was getting beat up at open mics but
you talk about clicky
comedy clicky yeah it was very clicky
it's hard to get in clicks
it's still clicky and she came to the
store one night destroyed
and i'm like i got two lines of coke in
me i already went up on stage
you know you came at the perfect time
what's going on and she's like
uh it's not gonna happen again between
us
i have a boyfriend and then she started
saying that we don't even have sex
we lay next to each other and my
positive vibes
go into his positive vibes and we don't
need to have sex that's so
yesterday oh this is a new way of doing
sex and i have the best
spoken word in the bedroom i have the
best orgasms in my life
and i'm listening to this [ __ ] going uh
all right listen
what's the problem and she's like i just
want somebody to see me and i'm like who
would you want to see it
and she's like i don't know a management
team there used to be a pay phone
next to the woman's bathroom in the
hallway when you walk down the stairs at
the thing
and i remember looking at it going so
what do you want me to call i don't know
it's 10 30 at night
who would you want me to call and she's
like i don't know who's the best manager
i go three yards
and i went into my pocket and i got a
quarter and i put in the pay
and you could see me hanging up and i
just dialed
seven numbers i'm like three yards give
me such and such
and it's at night and it's at night and
she's looking at me like
she didn't see me hang up the phone i'm
saying everybody do better
okay everybody i go to uh
i go listen i'm standing here with
whatever her name is
she wants you to see it when's the next
time you're doing a showcase
tuesday at the store though you're
available tuesday at the store not by
now
any smart girl would say give me your
phone [ __ ] you
let me talk to somebody no she's like
why can't you tuesday at 80 and i go
tuesday at eight be at the store this
you could do every day and i just hung
up the phone
the quarter out from the bottom i
thought we all seen this
and next you know we're in the belly
room bathroom upstairs
which is a hot spot and i remember we
had like sex and she had like dirty
fingernails and i'm like
i'm gonna go home and take a good shower
i didn't have a good house at that time
i lived in a [ __ ] car so so that's
the underrated that's
under embellished that's the under
embellished underrated
god sexual relations with her yeah how
many times maybe 20.
how many other women that did this to
none of them but
i will remember there was a meek
japanese girl
who came in for a while
me they usually are the japanese god
bless them
she just got out of a war like in her
world she had the straw hat
with the cup of rice and she was coming
at the store
she had grown up being a fan of tamayo
atsuko
it's maya tsuki so she's like i want to
be tamayo
i want to be tomayo you know tell me and
i was kind of nice to her oh my god that
was very nice
yeah this is the [ __ ] that you don't
tell people that people need to know
yeah i was very kind to her
and after about three weeks a dress
started getting more and more
japanesey which means they started
wearing less and less clothes
she started wearing monster boots with
hot pants
oh less japanese i got it okay yeah yeah
yeah i see a t-shirt
a little bite-sized titties sticking out
and i'm seeing this [ __ ]
trial size just to let you know that you
know
there's a good side and a bad side to
joey diaz this is one girl that
actually pretty much came to me in
japanese
and said to me in other words you know i
do
you know whatever stays time and whoa
i'm like oh here we go and you know i
said you know what tonight i'm full
like i'm okay tonight like i'm coked up
it's not yeah and i'll never forget
though like a month later
they were running a train behind the
stage
and the bar by her at like 11 o'clock
and the male bartender was like what am
i gonna do she wanted she went back they
were both on
for stage time you know i saw situations
like that
there was a girl that would come down
every sunday with a wig on
one of the prettiest girls you've ever
seen in your life and i caught
to after like a month i go where you
redhead a month ago
yeah well i just like to switch wigs
then i would stand in the front
remember i was a doormat so i would
stand the front sometimes
and she always got out of black cars
those
in [ __ ] 19 yeah 78 those black yeah
that's
expensive yeah yeah yeah that was a big
deal somebody pulls up on a limo now you
laugh at them you're like yeah whatever
but no not the limos but i know you mean
like the town cars
yeah the sedan one that i asked i go
what are you doing she goes oh you
wouldn't understand
and i remember her like pulling me aside
going
i really want to be a stand-up comedy
but nobody will help me
listen when you tell a seasoned comedian
and again
if you want to write for rolling stone
or whatever you want to take with this
podcast remember one thing
when a woman come to you in comedy and
says
i don't know what to do when i need help
seven out of ten comics what do they say
to you
i got you covered yeah don't worry about
none let's go back to like
my apartment and nine out of ten of them
are full of [ __ ]
and none of the time they're not full of
[ __ ] and then when they realize they
don't sleep with you they're not your
friend they don't talk to you
yeah i always try to talk to those women
you know i you grow in comedy and you
see the weaknesses
and like i told you guys last week one
night lee and i were coming back from
pasadena
and we started talking about my trouble
[ __ ] oh the triple runs i've never done
that what i saw on the triple
people it's crazy stories yeah i
remember i got off out of the car with
him
my body was shivering because it was
just crazy like
this yeah that you know finger in this
one
there was a [ __ ] air force base but
it's like whatever i don't
there's a comedy show called the
degenerates of comedy you did it why did
they call
like did any of the comics get offended
you called us degeneres
we are for the most part we are we're
[ __ ] animals on the road for them i
mean i can't say that about women
all the time because like or on the road
a little bit more nervous than a male
comic
of course 10 times over and it's still a
bar
it's a bar it's a nightclub they're
partying
it still doesn't matter it doesn't
excuse what i did next week
and it's not going to excuse what's
about to happen in the next couple weeks
because they made a lot of calls and you
know what
i didn't get one [ __ ] call you know
why because i wouldn't push a negative
narrative
and that's what they want they want
anything
negative they want anything negative you
know i would love
i wish people address it you know in the
right way
i haven't remembered you know i had to
look back and go well
i think of a couple situations one of
one which
i spoke with the podcast i'm not going
to tell the name to give you ammunition
i spoke of a person i had a problem with
when i first met her
we were doing a couple lines of coke and
i told her she had nice teddies
and she played it off like you know
nobody's ever told me this before
you're a pig really well oh i love shock
i love this is what i know about you
yeah and a couple weeks later i go to a
party and i see it with somebody and
it's like
you were trying to play [ __ ] virgin
mary and you got busted i'm not afraid
but i that's what i'm saying like
everybody right now feels like they're
all in shock like oh my god this is what
happens at nightclubs
oh my god what does comics talk dirty
comics embellish [ __ ] you emails that
would it would make you [ __ ]
i will be listen i will be and not one
person has called me
about anything from the comedy store and
i've been there for calling anybody who
matters well but here's the thing i've
been there from
i don't have any credits like that
everybody who
i mean i've heard in these articles and
these
interviews that adam's name has come up
and
i don't know why this is crazy has come
up who's the sweetest guy in the world
adam r adams what did you call him
adam angle i don't [ __ ] let him eat
ebay just call me ebay i don't know how
many people's names have come up that
i've said
what are you talking about why is his
name because if he
it here's the thing like back in the day
girls will come up to me and be like how
do i get spots how do i get spot how do
i get a showcase how do i get whatever
it was like
whether they were passed and not getting
spots or whether they were
trying to get past right because both
happen
when you can get past like mitzi said
she would be like ugh
i made a mistake on that after i saw him
and she'd stop giving them spots
one person one guy got really pissed off
and went to mitzi and was like why am i
not getting spots and she goes okay i'll
have you reshell case and then she
unpassed that [ __ ]
for making him sit making her sit
through that and it was the only person
i ever saw her do that too but it made
me laugh so i would
immediately tell people don't talk to
mitzi if you've been past
here's little tricks you can do like and
it was something as simple as send scott
some tequila or
wine yeah i would tell people all the
time send
cigarettes whatever it was that the the
town coordinator
could casually bring your name up in
front of mitzi
and spark her memory whether it good or
bad it'll work
and it did so then people would say how
can i get spots
should i [ __ ] this guy this guy told me
if i blow him that he'll help me and i
go
who would help you if you no he's going
to come and forget you
and i go if you want to know who to [ __ ]
to get into the club
if it's not mitchy sure you're doing it
wrong because she's the only one
that can put you on stage up until
she got real real sick and tommy started
there was one time when me and corey one
week
where mitzi was real sick in the late
90s
and she was she went to get stem cell
injections
i think bob uh wheeler took her and she
was
you know it was her first like bout with
this [ __ ]
her sickness and so she asked us to do
the lineup
and we corey and i were devastated
nervous wreck we don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings we love everybody
so we copied mitzi's format that was one
week
we still weren't in charge of anything
really
we just copied mitzi's format and then
if
we joke about this all the time or at
least rick and i do on the comedy store
podcast how
when she came back and started doing it
she literally would just go to ace so
the con
it would be like aaron cater a metamed
like whoever was [ __ ] ace
got on the lineup because she was
getting her health was declining
so then tommy duncan left tommy got in
there
and then once he saw that she was really
really declining
and he started doing the lineup he would
then
unfortunately [ __ ] with people and you
know well
you know if you do this you know he had
his own narrative
and his favorites were whitney and
crystalia
and mitzi didn't pass them tommy did
technically like whatever and
because he saw these are going to be the
future or whatever
he saw something in them and he was
passing and he was a dick to a lot of
people he was
but he was the town coordinator and
technically she gave him the reins to do
that
and the only other person that had that
was adam
because he was thrown into it but adam
showcases people
he doesn't give sexual [ __ ] favors
for
getting stage time and he doesn't not
give you stage time
if you didn't give him or don't like him
because i've had people come up to me
and be like he doesn't like me
he doesn't yeah he doesn't like your
stand-up you're taking a personal
like you you he asked you out and you
said no
and now you think that's why you're not
getting sick you're not funny you need
to [ __ ]
reevaluate or you could be funny but
just maybe he doesn't think you're funny
enough for the lineups he's putting
together
and if you're [ __ ] hurt by that [ __ ]
you i'm sorry
would you go to every casting director
and be like how did i not get in this
movie i'm perfect for it
and then just be like well b it's
because i was supposed to go out with
him or i was supposed to go out with her
and now they're holding a grudge
that's not how it works i don't know i'm
rattling but i'm pissed that's why
you're absolutely right because i'm
pissed it's just
you're you're you're changing you're
changing the narrative first of all
what with what is going on with chris
lee i'm like i said i'm
thrilled these girls spoke up right and
if he did something bad that will
[ __ ] come out
it will happen you will get your justice
but don't
change it and take away from something
that needs to be dealt with for real
because you didn't get [ __ ] spots at
the comedy store stop it and not one
person has come to me and said
no that's not true because you know that
because they know i know the real truth
i i watched it even with adam i've been
doing stand-up for 13 years adam took
over
probably what uh six years ago seven
years ago six
ish seven yeah so and he was thrown into
it
reluctantly he did not want to do this
he did not want that job nobody
wants that [ __ ] job nobody wants the
job of telling
you're good enough to get on this lineup
or you're not man or woman
and the other thing is with the women
they're trying to [ __ ]
men and women are all the same where
there is no gender
but but then when there's a [ __ ]
problem all of a sudden there's a gender
right all of a sudden these are males or
monsters and
they're trying to hurt women and not all
male
males are [ __ ] i have six brothers i
would say
some of them are [ __ ] some of them
aren't you know whatever
i i'm again i'm flipping out because i
just don't know what
i'm just happy that you were there 97
to 2000 you witnessed me you witnessed
me at my lowest points on drugs
yeah and to say i [ __ ] my way in i've
heard that one too because i
slept with dice that's my second
ex-fiance i wasn't even doing stand-up
when i was with dice
and and when i started doing stand-up
respectfully
because he was the higher up technically
not because he's male
just because he's [ __ ] andrew dice
clay and he started at
the comedy store so when i started doing
it i called him and i called mitzi
because i have respect for them and i
didn't want them to think
oh i'm [ __ ] crazy i'm gonna go there
because i'm dice's ex and i'm gonna [ __ ]
with him
and stay at the store or uh you know i'm
an ex-waitress and i want to [ __ ]
piss off mitzi by doing stand-up i
didn't do it for the wrong reasons
i called them to say hey i'm gonna try
this is this okay
if i come to the store i i asked
permission
and mitzi let me she she told me to do
the belly room
uh and i did and then she showcased i i
showcased three or
three times for mitzi it took me three
years to get past and i was her personal
assistant i did everything
i went out of the country with mitzi
like we were tight
so and then with andrew he took me on
the road
and i didn't do i got booed off the
stage
and he put me in the [ __ ] back burner
for a year
and then i had a re-showcase for him so
don't tell me i didn't do the [ __ ]
leg work and that i [ __ ] my way into
a comedy store paint regular because
i'll beat the [ __ ] out of you one
two i worked my ass off for it
everything i got and and there's a lot
of women that they talk like that about
and one of them is whitney cummings that
came
somebody said it to me and i thought
[ __ ] you man we were in the same show
she said something to me worked every i
wake up and i say what would whitney do
that's how i [ __ ] think
whether you like her stand up or not do
i think whitney's the funniest person on
the planet
no but i think she's [ __ ] brilliant
she puts her time in and she puts her
[ __ ] time in and
bust her goddamn ass she wasn't she was
sleeping with regular
[ __ ] guys like the rest of us nobody
special
i can think of four four three different
guys that she was dating
they were regular [ __ ] guys they
weren't they didn't have any power
she was just smarter than you and you
don't [ __ ] like it
she said something to me that made sense
for you eliza
eliza too eliza's [ __ ] great ali wong
leslie jones who the [ __ ] the leslie
[ __ ] leslie's phenomenal
she said when you come to this town you
and you go to the comedy store you have
two decisions
you can either suck dick or put your
ponytail into the hat
and become one of the guys yeah you've
done that
you're one of the guys i've talked about
why because you had nine brothers
and you know exactly how they talk they
scratch their balls
they sniff their fingers they're
monsters but i love it
i would tell you right in front of them
how they [ __ ] the neighbor in the ass
talk yeah she was half [ __ ] [ __ ] if
i set up
yeah and you laughed a little bit but
that was what uh you know that they said
coursed
there was no need to coerce nobody
nobody called her
these girls were willing god bless me i
mean there was many others and i've
heard many other stories
and like i said i'm not here with this
podcast now the next step is where this
goes
where does this go if it goes any
further it's dumb i gotta be it's gonna
go further
it's going to go further they're going
to pick apart every person anybody
that's ever laughed at richard pryor
should be executed
he grew up in a whorehouse and that's
how he saw women
it's going to go further and at least
for me it is
they made some calls they called seattle
let's see why i left seattle
you know were they worried you have a
[ __ ] past you're pretty open about it
oh i am
they're going after clubs for certain
reasons for not doing
i heard this in an email a stricter
background checks in the comics to make
sure that sexual
predators like now they have us they
have oh my gosh how the [ __ ] are we
gonna
prevent that about the wednesday i
celebrate 20 years with my girlfriend
when you saw us terry uh my girlfriend
that's your wife [ __ ]
in my head we've been together 20 years
wow
so you gotta remember when i started
dating terry i was still snorting coke
but i was at the store and i couldn't
really do nothing because now
she'd know it she was right there
watching me yeah so for you
[ __ ] that
want to say something and terry don't
[ __ ] around jerry don't [ __ ] around
terry was the if i worked five nights
terry works she will
[ __ ] you up jack that's my girl that's
why i love terry like terry worked five
nights
all right i need a little national
anthem real quick today
because there's something we got to talk
about people are having do's and nots
and we got to do some national anthem i
don't know any dates coming up
no you [ __ ] they canceled everything
no not till sep
uh no i'm and um when is it [ __ ] august
6
i'm at phoenix at the house of comedy
august but that's not to august my july
date got cancelled in vancouver
tweeted and we'll retweet it i love it
thank you so much
and uh no i'm happy to have you on today
because i wanna sorry if i went off
a little bit you were there okay you
were there my wife was there so
listen terry what the [ __ ] they're gonna
come up with
because i got a thousand stories i got a
millionaire
call that whatever story you want to
come up with
there's got to be a back end to it about
six months ago
i get home way before cove in november
okay
and some girl who lost you know what it
is she's a cute blonde girl she was
married to an
owner of a comedy club and
i always considered her a dear friend i
saw her at the haha when i was trying to
make a comeback
and i wasn't going to the store and one
night i
go on twitter on a saturday it's gotta
be 11 30 and i
read her tweet which says joey once
went into a bathroom in the back of a
bus while i was in the bathroom
and i thought about it for a second and
i go holy [ __ ]
that's right in 98 we were doing a roger
paul gig
oh wow back at the bus and i had to go
to the bathroom
and when she found out i had packaged
she asked me if i'd do a package so
usually do a package in the bathroom
so i go you didn't mention we were doing
the package
you're just going to all of a sudden
that's what we're only going to put out
half the story
everything's half the [ __ ] story so i
was like [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that i wrote to have a
package so
i know that uh you know
what they're trying to leave it out to
make them
we got 20 years right here i got 20
years who i've been with at the house
my wife was a wages at the store and she
can attest to
[ __ ] want to raise your hand come on
with it there was a friend of ours who
recently died a big guy
his wife became a saint all of a sudden
she is
she also got smacked around at the store
yeah she got smacked around a couple
places so far to raise yeah but for me
from me this time but this is the thing
with terry
terry was there when we were all just so
you know
the cesspool the comedy world is and a
night club becomes when you're there all
the time
there was a part where we had a herpes
outbreak
because we were all [ __ ] each other
and uh i'm up
well i wasn't really in that part but i
was
in that and we all had to go get tested
for herpes
and i don't want this to reflect on the
store or any other place no no i'm
saying every night club has
there was a lot of love there there
still is a lot of love there
you know i feel bad for dalia and all
this when we have to go back
but these stories we're talking about
change
oh yeah we'll be back no but i'm saying
this they won't
they won't happen any they don't happen
as much as they used to because their
people don't realize the cameras at the
store
you just can't get mitty was sick she
wasn't there she wasn't
watching you get [ __ ] up you get your
suck detectors thrown out
you pop up from somebody's zoom while
they took it to the grandmother the
final steps
kill martin god bless her lori
phenomenal
diana kovan there you are getting your
dick sucked in the bathroom in the main
room
squirting some girl's eyeball and i'm
telling you is there a napkin back here
and you're like nah
not really a linux they got light bulbs
though you want to light
up to wipe your right ball with any
dates so you got
june july i mean uh july got canceled
i'm sorry i'm at the house of comedy in
august i believe it's august 6th
7th and 8th i don't know let's keep your
[ __ ] prayers open
we got july 21st at oxnard
uh that's where they'll start and then
hopefully july 29th
through august 1st in breyer if the
covert disappears
if you [ __ ] don't start
marching against something else next
week
you know martian lives matter let's do
that one because the margin got
[ __ ] run over in new mexico how about
[ __ ] anything
i didn't talk about that joey don't joke
about that i heard you're being
insensitive to martians
i know [ __ ] them too all they've ever
done is [ __ ] create people go crazy i
saw marshall
i saw my [ __ ] him and bigfoot [ __ ]
boat
and uh i love you at all my heart i
appreciate the video
i appreciate it thank you thank you for
people watching
because these [ __ ] obviously
don't know and number two let me explain
something to you
hit me with the national anthem
[Music]
i feel like i have to stand i got
nervous i want to find no flutes
my daddy's a marine it's got american
flag on it that's the one
real quick know that lower that so i can
talk over this get up you [ __ ]
it's monday the 30th whatever the [ __ ]
it is of
june enough is enough already
for three months we've been living in
[ __ ] misery
confusion we're broke we're hungry
we want [ __ ] answers stop blaming
china
stop it stay in your house move out of
that [ __ ] apartment
but most importantly social distance and
most importantly besides that
this is a crucial [ __ ] situation and
some of you
are not happy put your [ __ ] mask on
you [ __ ] maggot [ __ ] let me
tell you something
you think i like putting a [ __ ] mask
on i don't like putting the mask on
i gotta smell my own breath 50 years of
rotten teeth
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ]
breathing [ __ ] nose hairs i don't
want smelling the [ __ ] breath
either but you have to do it why because
we're trying to keep each other alive
how can we be so [ __ ] selfish you
know what you want to go to the bar
go [ __ ] yourself go to the liquor store
buy a bottle like every other american
and go outside and get three or four of
your friends and get [ __ ] up
no more [ __ ] parties no more
get-togethers
i don't want to see no black chicks
twinking with your ass
up and down they told you you can't eat
ass
and here you are spreading those [ __ ]
germs up in the air
i feel bad for midgets you [ __ ]
filthy [ __ ] animals
so do me one favor whether you agree or
disagree
when you're home when you're scratching
your balls listen i wouldn't put a mask
on either
i fought it and i could smell the fart
through the [ __ ] mask
so if i could fart and smell it through
the mask
outside at the park that means you can
maybe get a little corona vibe no
you can't get the corona virus what i'm
telling you is
it's a public [ __ ] nuisance now
pretty soon
people gonna get stuck getting hit in
the head with [ __ ] karate elbows and
[ __ ]
keep your mask on fourth of july is
coming do you want to be [ __ ] caught
up in the fourth of july
where's the music where's the meal
bubble started again
where's the music we're americans we
gotta [ __ ] join in now
and enough is enough put on your [ __ ]
mask
it's not self-respect it's not respect
for us
it's starting to be respect for
ourselves
i wear a map put it on more i want to
hear more i'm getting fired up here
don't make me [ __ ] get a bottle
rocket cutting
and make a chase different dresses at
the [ __ ]
groups you understand me get that mask
put it on shut your [ __ ] mouth you
[ __ ] little animals in miami you
[ __ ]
jungle spanish people down there you got
you should wear a mask as they would
when i came from cuba they put a mask
and goggles on me
that's how contagious i was all right so
go [ __ ] yourself don't make me break out
the goggles
you [ __ ] immigrant [ __ ] you're lucky
you're here
put on a [ __ ] mask it's a [ __ ]
right
and everybody else you [ __ ] white
people that think you're better than
everybody
because you pay taxes and you [ __ ]
drive a a prius
so what go [ __ ] yourself put on your
mask
black people they're trying to kill us
put on your mask
if it ain't a [ __ ] cop it's a bullet
now it's some chinese doing a laboratory
trying to kill you
and mexicans first of all if three is
over 200 pounds i don't want to say it
together
every time i see seven fat mexicans
coven is coming
it took out a family down in orange
county if you're seven that made
mexicans
and you're heavy knock it off invite
three skinny cousins who just got here
and ran the three miles no more than
four fat
mexicans can get together and that's
cuban salvation
you puerto ricans too you're not
excluded
you have black and you have spanish you
you guys
they roll the dice down there in puerto
rico put your [ __ ] mask on
social distance and have a little
[ __ ] respect
you see a line [ __ ] six feet ten feet
put on your mask i don't enjoy it either
look at me i look like a [ __ ] i look
like i just got out the [ __ ] uh
sucking 300 dicks this is what you look
like when they throw you out
what happened to him they ran a train
through him last night at the gay bar
with 300 dicks i don't like wearing a
mask
does it say in the american constitution
no but
right now as americans what's going on
and the numbers in florida texas
arizona and california wear your [ __ ]
mask
it's monday go out there and be a
[ __ ] champion
the church what's happening now thanks
you i want to thank eleanor kerrigan
i want to thank [ __ ] lee lee leland
and i want to thank you guys for all the
support
of what's going on in each other's lives
you need
comedy i got the [ __ ] answer you
understand me
but it all starts with the mask i don't
give a [ __ ] you're gonna hate me for
this
but as part of the church us we gotta be
marines in this [ __ ]
we put on our mask have a great week
have a great monday god bless you
take this [ __ ] mu lee get this
[ __ ] mask off me
[Music]
foreign